so there's a great quote by the poet c8
which says the world is full of magic
things patiently waiting for our senses
to grow sharper in other words in our
search for the miraculous we find that
it's often right before our very eyes
but we fail to see it right we are blind
we cannot decipher but Henry Miller says
if we could pinpoint our attention right
we would see that even a blade of grass
when giving proper attention becomes a
magnificent world in itself and how do
we focus our attention with our tools
like the microscope we're even more
interested like the telescope as it
literally allows us to swallow the macro
right think of a Space Telescope which
as the poet author Ross Anderson
describes allows us to mainline space
and time through the optic nerve
literally a Space Telescope takes images
of the deep field takes images of the
universe and literally distills through
the sheer aesthetic impact the esthetic
force of its discoveries it distills the
complex the unfathomably complex
abstractions of astrophysics the
mathematics that is beyond our
understanding it literally distills that
a distinct euler expressions of color
and of light vindicating Keats the poet
famous couplet beauty is truth truth
ud right we see images of the universe
taken through a space telescope and we
realize this is nothing less my friends
as Ross Anderson says as nothing less
than an ontological awakened forceful
reckoning a reckoning with what is which
allows us to contemplate space and time
on a scale just shy of the infinite and
what does this do when we are cracked
open by our agitating consciousness
right in pain from the human condition
the mortal coil
all of a sudden connect with something
grander than itself connects with
something rating it with something
resplendent we are split apart by the
majesty of the universe by aw and we
become more than what we were we
experienced the astronaut overview
effect what Neil deGrasse Tyson calls
the cosmic perspective we see the big
picture we are transformed
we are reset we are filled with feelings
of grace and gratitude this this kind of
awe their appeal a possible by these
technological instruments such as Space
Telescope's enlarge us they be with us
and they oh my god what they do for the
mind is they allow us to fit the
universe through our brains and as I
ended my video on AH it comes out as
nothing less than poetry we as Carl
Sagan says we are star stuff and we
remember what we forgot
you